The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation, or to view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Hi.
Today we begin our study of
integral calculus, which had
its roots back in ancient
Greece, roughly 600 BC, and
began with an investigation
of the study of area.
In a certain manner of speaking,
today's lecture
could be called 'Calculus
Revisited Revisited', in the
sense that integral calculus
can be studied quite apart
from the fact that differential
calculus was ever invented.
We'll see later in this block
of material that there is a
wondrous relationship between
integral and differential
calculus, but perhaps the best
proof that integral calculus
can be studied independently of
differential calculus lies
in the fact that the ancient
Greek was doing integral
calculus in 600 BC, whereas
differential calculus did not
begin until about 1680 AD
with Sir Isaac Newton.
Well, at any rate then, what
we'll call today's lecture is
simply 'Two-dimensional Area'.
In other words, this is how
the subject began, with
studying the amount of space
in plane regions,
two-dimensional area, as opposed
to, say, as we'll talk
about later, three-dimensional
area, which is really a fancy
word for volume, et cetera.
But enough about that
for the time being.
Two-dimensional area, or
Calculus Revisited Revisited.
And to see what's happening over
here, the study of area
was the forerunner of integral
calculus as we now know it.
It began in ancient Greece,
roughly 600 BC.
The branch of calculus that
we've been studying up until
now in our course, differential
calculus, did not
begin until 1680 AD.
Notice, then, the interesting
juxtaposition in time.
In other words, pedagogically,
one seems to study
differential calculus before
integral calculus.
Chronologically, integral
calculus preceded differential
calculus by more than
2,000 years.
Now this is a rather
beautiful study.
It's one of the most aesthetic
parts of elementary
mathematics, namely the
simplicity with which the
Greek was able to tackle the
sophisticated problem of
finding areas in general.
He started with three basically
simple properties of
area, so simple that most of us
are willing to accept them
almost intuitively.
We'll call these the
'Axioms for Area'.
And simply stated, they
were the following.
One, that the area of a
rectangle is the base times
the height.
Two, if one region is contained
within another, the
area of the contained region is
less than or equal to-- in
other words, can be no greater
than-- that of
the containing region.
Roughly speaking, the
smaller the region,
the smaller its area.
And finally, written slightly
more formally here, the old
high-school axiom for plane
geometry, that the area of the
whole equals the sum of the
areas of the parts, that if a
region 'R' is subdivided into a
union of mutually exclusive
pieces, then the area of the
entire region is equal to the
sum of the areas of the
constituent parts.
And with just these three
axioms, the ancient Greek
invented a technique for finding
areas that today is
still known by its original
name, the 'Method of
Exhaustion'.
And here, exhaustion does not
refer to the fact that we get
tired using the system, even
though, as we shall soon see,
it's quite intricate.
It refers to the fact that we
take the region whose area we
want to find and exhaust the
space by squeezing it between
regions which are made
up of rectangles.
Stated more precisely,
given a region 'R'--
and I'll define this more
precisely later-- we squeeze
it between two networks
of rectangles,
the idea being what?
That we know what the area
of a rectangle is, and
consequently, by the fact that
the area of the whole equals
the sum of the areas of the
parts, if we have a
rectangular network, knowing how
to find the area of each
rectangle, we know how
to find the area of
the rectangular network.
Now, rather than to wax on like
this philosophically,
let's tackle a specific
problem.
In fact, give or take a little
bit, this is specifically the
problem that Archimedes dealt
with in finding the area of
parabolic segments way back,
as I say, in the
300 to 600 BC era.
As an example, consider
the following.
We wish to determine the area of
the region 'R', 'A sub R',
where the region 'R' is that
region which is bounded above
by the curve 'y' equals 'x
squared', below by the x-axis,
on the left by the y-axis,
and on the right by the
line 'x' equals 1.
In other words, this
region in here.
Now here's the way we put the
squeeze on it, and we'll start
this quite gradually.
The first thing that we observe
is that if we draw a
line parallel to the x-axis
through the point (1 , 1), the
highest point of our region
here, we construct a rectangle
which contains our region 'R'.
And since 'R' is contained in
the rectangle, the area of the
region 'R' must be less than
the area of the rectangle.
But notice that this particular
rectangle that
we've just constructed has its
base equal to 1, its height
equal to 1.
Therefore by our first axiom,
its area is 1 times 1, or 1.
Also, since intuitively, area
is a positive thing, we see
just from this quick diagram
that whatever the area of the
region is, we now have it
bounded between 0 and 1.
We have an upper bound.
We have a lower bound.
We have this thing caught, OK?
Now, there's still a lot of
space between 0 and 1.
The method of exhaustion
refines this idea.
Namely, what we do next
is we say, look at--
instead of just drawing one big
rectangle like this, why
don't we partition the base
of our region 'R'
into two equal parts?
In other words, let's locate the
point 1/2, which of course
is midway between 0 and 1.
Now what I can do is I can
circumscribe two rectangles,
one of which is the rectangle
whose height corresponds to
the x-coordinate
equaling 1/2--
that means the y-coordinate
is 1/4--
and the second rectangle, the
one whose x-coordinate--
the x-coordinate of the height
is 1, and since 'y' equals 'x
squared', the height
is also 1.
You see, notice that by picking
a region which is a
curve which is always rising,
the lowest point of each
region is the point that's
furthest to the left.
And the highest point of each
region is the point that's
furthest to the right.
And keeping this in mind, you
see by making rectangles
corresponding to the points
furthest to the right in each
interval, I get a rectangle
which contains the portion of
the region 'R' that
I'm talking about.
In other words, if I look at
this rectangular network, my
region 'R' is contained
inside that.
Consequently, its area is less
than the area of the
rectangular network.
Now, what is the area of this
rectangular network?
Well, the big rectangle has its
base equal to 1/2 and its
height equal to 1.
So its area is 1/2.
The small rectangle has its
base equal to 1/2 and its
height equal to 1/4.
Since its area is the
base times the
height, its area is 1/8.
1/8 plus 1/2 is 5/8.
In other words, the area of the
rectangular network which
contains 'R' is 5/8.
Consequently, the area of
the region 'R' must
be less than 5/8.
On the other hand, notice that
the lowest point in the second
interval corresponds to
'x' equaling 1/2.
In other words, notice that
this particular rectangle,
whose base is 1/2 and whose
height is 1/4, that this
rectangle here is inscribed
in the region 'R'.
Its area is 1/8.
And since it's contained within
the region 'R', its
area must be less than the
area of the region 'R'.
And so we're now certain that
whatever the area of the
region 'R' is, it's between
1/8 and 5/8.
And by the way, notice in terms
of these shaded regions,
that even though this is an
approximation which is too
large to be the right answer,
it is closer to being the
right answer than this
approximation here.
In other words, notice that
the difference between the
overestimate here and the
overestimate here is this
amount in here.
You see, we've chopped off
part of the error.
But we'll talk about that,
as I say, in more
detail in the notes.
What I'd like to do is to give
you an overall view of what's
happening over here.
You see, to generalize the
method of exhaustion, we do
what the mathematician
usually does.
Instead of saying, let's divide
the base of the region
into two equal parts, or three
equal parts, or four equal
parts, we say, let's divide
it into 'n' equal parts.
Now if we divide this base into
'n' equal parts, since
the whole region--
the whole length is 0 to 1,
dividing into 'n' equal parts
means that my points of division
will be '1/n', '2/n',
'3/n', et cetera, right down
to 'n/n', which is 1.
What I do now is I pick the
right endpoint of each point
in that partition to
draw my rectangle.
You see, each of these
rectangles that I draw this
way contains the corresponding
part of my region 'R'.
Consequently, the area of this
rectangular network must be an
upper bound for the area
of my region 'R'.
Now, because it's going to be an
upper bound, and because it
depends on what the value of
'n' is, I will denote that
upper bound by 'U sub n'.
And what will 'U sub n' be?
It's the sum of the areas
of these circumscribed
rectangles.
And it's not difficult to
see from this picture.
Let's take a look.
Since this rectangle has its
height corresponding to the
x-coordinate equaling '1/n', and
since the y-coordinate is
the square of the x-coordinate,
the height of
this rectangle will be
''1/n' squared'.
The base is '1/n'.
So the area of that
circumscribed rectangle is
''1/n' squared' times '1/n'.
Similarly, the next rectangle
here has its height
corresponding to the
x-coordinate '2/n'.
So its height is ''2/n'
squared'.
Keep in mind the y-coordinate
is the square of the
x-coordinate here.
The base of all of these
rectangles is '1/n'.
And proceeding in this way, I
finally come down to the last
rectangle, whose
height is what?
Well, the x-coordinate is 1,
so the y-coordinate is 1.
To keep my form here, I'll
write that as 'n/n'.
Its height is therefore
''n/n' squared'.
The base of that rectangle is
'1/n', so the area of that
last rectangle is ''n/n'
squared' times '1/n'.
Now you see that's what?
That's an area which is too
large to be 'A sub R'.
Well, let's take a look now and
see what's happening here.
Notice that each of these terms
has an 'n cubed' in the
denominator.
So I can factor out the
'n cubed' term.
And what I'm left
with is what?
The sum of the first
'n' squares.
1 squared plus 2 squared plus 3
squared, et cetera, plus et
cetera, 'n squared'.
In other words, this tells me
how to find 'U sub n' for any
value of 'n'.
And we'll talk about that some
more in a little while.
That's an upper bound.
In a corresponding way, I can
also find a lower bound.
Namely, what I'll do now is pick
the smallest rectangle in
each region.
In other words, I'll now
inscribe rectangles inside my
region 'R', and therefore find
a rectangular region whose
area is less than that
of the region 'R'.
And to do that, without going
through the details, notice
that essentially all I have to
do is shift each of these
rectangles over by
one partition.
Namely, notice, for example,
that the smallest height in
the second partition here is the
one which corresponds to
the height '1/n'.
In other words, what I do
now is, to inscribe the
rectangles, I just shift
everything over like this.
And leaving the details out, and
letting you verify these
for yourselves, I
can again mimic
exactly what I did before.
The only difference being now,
that instead of the height of
the last rectangle being 'n/n',
notice that it's 'n -
1' over 'n', squared.
In other words, the
x-coordinate is
'n - 1' over 'n'.
The y-coordinate is the square
of the x-coordinate.
In other words, notice that this
point here gives rise to
the height of the lowest
rectangle that can be
inscribed in my last
portion here.
So without further ado, it turns
out that 'L sub n', the
lower estimate, is '1 over 'n
cubed'' times the sum of the
first 'n - 1' squares.
OK.
Now, let's keep track of just
what it is that we've done
over here so far.
What we've done is what?
For each 'n', we have squeezed
'A sub R' between two numbers,
one number being an upper
approximation, one number
being a lower approximation.
Now notice that the 'U sub
n' and the 'L sub n' are
functions of 'n'.
'A sub R' is a constant.
That's the area of
the region 'R'.
What the method of exhaustion
means is simply this.
We say, look.
Let's take the limit of the 'L
sub n's as 'n' approaches
infinity, and let's take the
limit of the 'U sub n's as 'n'
approaches infinity, observing
that for each 'n', 'A sub R'
is squeezed between these two.
Consequently, since 'A sub R' is
squeezed between these two
for each 'n', it must be
when we go to the limit.
In other words, whatever 'A sub
R' is, it must be between
these two limits.
Now here's the key step.
It turns out, at least in this
particular problem, that the
limit of 'L sub n' as 'n' goes
to infinity is the same as the
limit of 'U sub n' as 'n'
goes to infinity.
And the best way to see that
without becoming too fancy at
this stage of the game is to
observe that for a given 'n',
the difference between
'U sub n' and 'L
sub n' is just '1/n'.
And again, I'll just indicate
to you from this diagram how
we can see that.
Notice that back here, the way
we went from 'U sub n' to 'L
sub n' was we just pushed
over this whole
network by one unit.
In other words, the rectangle
that we squeezed out in going
from the upper sum to the
lower sum was just this
particular rectangle whose
height was 1 and
whose base was '1/n'.
In other words, the area that
was kicked out in going from
'L sub n' to 'U sub
n' is '1/n'.
This is what this thing
here says here.
This is worked out in
detail in the notes.
But again, I just want to go
through this thing quickly so
we get the idea of what's
happening over here.
In other words, since 'U sub n'
minus 'L sub n' is '1/n',
that's just another way
of saying what?
That the limit of this
difference is just the limit
of '1/n' as 'n' goes
to infinity.
But that's clearly 0.
In other words, these two limits
are the same because
their difference goes
to 0 in the limit.
Consequently, since these two
things are the same, and 'A
sub R' is caught between these
two, it must be that 'A sub R'
is equal to this common limit.
And that's precisely what the
method of exhaustion was.
We squeeze what we were looking
for between two
estimates which converge
towards each
other as 'n' got large.
Now, by the way, I'm going to
point out the fact that it's
very, very difficult
in general to find
what this limit is.
We're going to see
that in working a
few specific problems.
What I thought might
be informative--
without going through the
details right now, I have
taken the liberty of computing
'L sub n' and 'U sub n' in
this problem for 'n'
equals 1,000.
In other words, if we divided
this region into 1,000 equal
parts and took the network of
circumscribed rectangles and
inscribed rectangles, it would
turn out that the area of the
inscribed rectangles would
be 0.3328335, and for the
circumscribed rectangles,
0.3338335.
And by the way, notice how
this is borne out.
Notice that the difference
between these two is precisely
1/1000, and that is '1/n'
with 'n' equal to 1,000.
But that's not the important
point here.
The important point is that just
looking at this decimal
expansion, if I didn't know
anything else, I know that 'A
sub R' is caught between
these two.
Consequently, to two decimal
places, I can be sure that 'A
sub R' is 0.33.
And notice that if I want more
and more decimal place
accuracy, especially if I have
access to a desk calculator, I
don't really have to compute
the limit exactly.
I can feed the formula into
the machine and put the
squeeze on and get as
many decimal place
accuracy as I want.
By the way, as an aside, this is
exactly what we did in high
school, when we said things
like let pi equal 22/7.
Pi is not equal to 22/7.
Among other things, 22/7
is a rational number.
It's the ratio of two
whole numbers.
Pi is an irrational number.
What people really meant was
that you can't tell the
difference between pi and 22/7
to two decimal places.
They both begin 3.14.
And consequently, if all you
wanted to measure was to two
decimal digits, you could
use 22/7 as the
approximation for pi.
But if you wanted to squeeze out
more places, you'd have to
use a more refined approach.
By the way, let me point out
that one of the reasons that I
chose the curve 'y' equals 'x
squared' to work with was--
you may recall that back in our
discussion of mathematical
induction, one of the problems
that we worked on was to show
how we find by induction the
recipe for the sum of the
first 'n' squares.
And by way of review, let me
recall for you the fact that
the sum of the first 'n' squares
was given by ''n'
times 'n + 1' times
'2n + 1'' over 6.
OK?
In other words, going back to
our recipe for 'U sub n', I
can now replace 1 squared plus
2 squared plus et cetera 'n
squared' by ''n' times 'n +
1' times '2n + 1'' over 6.
And if I now divide through by
'n cubed' judiciously, namely
canceling out one 'n' with this
'n', dividing 'n + 1' by
'n' and '2n + 1' by 'n', I get
that 'U sub n' is '1/6 'n + 1'
over 'n'' times ''2n
+ 1' over 'n''.
And that can be written even
more suggestively as 1/6 times
'1 + '1/n'' times '2 + '1/n''.
And I can now put a very
nice mathematical
interpretation on this.
Mainly, notice that no matter
how big 'n' is, '1 + '1/n'' is
bigger than 1, you see, because
'1/n' is positive.
And '2 + '1/n'' is
bigger than 2.
Consequently, whatever this is,
it's bigger than 1/6 times
1 times 2, which is 1/3.
In other words, for each 'n', 'U
sub n' is greater than 1/3.
It also happens that
as 'n' gets larger,
'U sub n' gets smaller.
Again, looking at this recipe,
the bigger 'n' is, the bigger
is our denominator, and the
bigger the denominator, the
smaller the fraction.
And finally, notice that as 'n'
goes to infinity, 'U sub
n' gets arbitrarily close to
1/3 in value, because '1/n'
approaches 0 in the limit.
In fact, it is 0 in the limit.
So summarizing then, each 'U
sub n' is bigger than 1/3.
As 'n' increases, 'U sub n'
decreases, and the limit of 'U
sub n' as 'n' approaches
infinity is 1/3.
Pictorially, what this means
is that if we locate 1/3 on
the number line, the 'U sub n's
converge uniformly in the
sense of moving steadily towards
the left, towards 1/3
as the limit.
Well, that's an upper squeeze.
The lower squeeze comes from
the fact that in a similar
way, we can show that
'L sub n' is 1/6--
and look at how close this
comes to parallelling the
structure of 'U sub n'-- '1 -
'1/n'' times '2 - '1/n''.
Minuses here instead of pluses
as we had above.
Now, mimicking what we did
before, notice now
that for each 'n'--
since we're subtracting
over here--
for each 'n', 'L sub n'
is less than 1/3.
But now since the fractions
get smaller as 'n' gets
bigger, and you're subtracting
them, the
difference becomes larger.
In other words, now notice
that each 'L sub n'
is less than 1/3.
As 'n' increases, 'L
sub n' increases.
And the limit of 'L sub
n' as 'n' approaches
infinity is also 1/3.
In other words, if we draw this
in back here, look what
the 'L sub n's are doing.
They're all less than 1/3, but
they move steadily towards the
right as 'n' increases,
pushing in on 1/3.
And since 'A sub R' is always
caught between these two, and
these two converge relentlessly
upon 1/3, it must
be, by definition, if there is
an area at all, that the area
of the region 'R' must
be exactly 1/3.
And by the way, just as a
quick aside, notice how
important it is that we not
only have upper and lower
bounds which converge.
They must converge to
the same value.
In other words, what I'm saying
is suppose all the 'U
sub n's get arbitrarily close
to what I call script 'L sub
1', and all the 'L sub n's
get arbitrarily close
to 'L2' over here.
Then all I'm saying is, all we
would know is that the area
was someplace between
'L2' and 'L1'.
We couldn't conclude that it
was exactly equal to 1/3.
You see, the method of
exhaustion implies that all
the error, all the room for
doubt, is squeezed out.
By the way, there was nothing
sacred about choosing 'y'
equals 'x squared'.
We could generalize this.
And we'll do this kind of
rapidly because I just want
you to hear what I'm saying.
This is all written out
in great detail in our
supplementary notes.
The idea is this.
Let 'f' be any positive,
continuous function on 'a',
'b' and non-decreasing.
The non-decreasing part is just
for the convenience of
being able to locate the high
and low points of each
partition point conveniently.
Partition 'a', 'b' into 'n'
equal parts, calling the first
partition point 'x sub 0', the
last partition point 'x sub
n', and the points in between
'x1' up through ''x 'n - 1''.
In other words, we've
partitioned this closed
interval into 'n' equal parts.
And what we can now
do is what?
Pick the lowest point in each
region, the highest point in
each region, to form
a rectangle.
We can form 'U sub
n' and 'L sub n'.
And you see it's just what?
For 'L sub n', you just pick
this height, which is 'f of 'x
sub 0'', 'f of a'.
The base is 'delta x'.
You just add these all up until
you get to your last
inscribed partition point.
That's 'x sub 'n - 1''.
OK.
'U sub n' is the same thing,
only now your first rectangle
has its height corresponding
to 'x' equals 'x1'.
Consequently, the height
is 'f of x1'.
The base is 'delta x'.
Where in each of these, 'delta
x' is just what?
This total length, which
is 'b - a', divided
into 'n' equal parts.
And to review the so-called
sigma notation that we have in
our course--
in this section in the textbook,
and we'll have
exercises on this to make sure
that you are familiar with
this notation, the shortcut
notation for writing this sum
is given by this.
We add up 'f of 'x sub
k'' times 'delta x'.
As a subscript, 'k' is allowed
to vary from 1 to 'n'.
And here we form the same sum,
only now the subscript 'k'
varies from 0 to 'n - 1'.
At any rate, the observations
are this.
That 'U sub n' and 'L sub n'
converge to the same limit.
In fact, this isn't
too hard to show.
If you just algebraically
subtract 'L sub n' from 'U sub
n', notice that the only terms
that won't cancel are
the last term here.
See, 'f of 'x sub n'' times
'delta x' has no counterpart
here, because this ends with
the subscript 'n - 1'.
Similarly, there is no 0
subscript in 'U sub n', so
this term won't cancel.
To make a long story short, if
we just subtract 'L sub n'
from 'U sub n', that difference
will be 'f of 'x
sub n'' times 'delta x'
minus 'f of 'x sub 0''
times 'delta x'.
See, that's just this difference
over here.
'Delta x' is 'b - a' over 'n'.
'x sub n' was called 'b'.
'x sub 0' was called 'a'.
In other words, the difference
between 'U sub n' and 'L sub
n' is just 'f of b' minus
'f of a' times
''b - a' over 'n''.
And the important thing to
observe is that 'a', 'b', 'f
of a', and 'f of b' are
fixed constants.
The only thing that depends on
'n' is this denominator.
Consequently, as 'n' goes to
infinity, since the rest of
this thing is a constant, the
whole term goes to 0.
In other words, the difference
between 'Un' and 'Ln' goes to
0 in the limit.
That means that the limit of 'U
sub n', as 'n' approaches
infinity, equals the limit
of 'L sub n' as
'n' approaches infinity.
'A sub R' is always caught
between 'L sub n' and 'U sub
n' by this very construction.
Consequently, what this means is
that the area of the region
'R' must equal this
common limit.
Now by the way, this
looks very hard.
And it is difficult.
In fact, in general, these
limits are very hard to find.
The point that I thought would
be interesting to mention at
this stage of the game is that
if all we want is an estimate
for the area under the curve,
there are faster and better
ways of doing this.
You see, the beauty of this
technique here is that it's a
technique for exhausting
the space completely.
We find the exact
areas this way.
Let me give you a for
instance here.
Namely, let me explain to you
what we mean by trapezoidal
approximations.
Let's take the same region,
'y' equals 'x squared'.
And now, we'll divide it
into two parts here.
And what we'll do is we'll
replace the arc of the curve
by the straight line segment,
the chord, that joins two
points here.
In other words, using the
accented chalk here to
illustrate this.
What I'm going to do is instead
of finding the area of
the region 'R', I'm going to
find the area of the region
which has the top of
'R' replaced by
these two line segments.
All I want you to observe is
that this first region here is
a triangle whose height is 1/4
and whose base is 1/2.
Consequently, its area, being
one half the base times the
height, is 1/16.
The second region here is a
trapezoid whose bases are 1
and 1/4 and whose
height is 1/2.
And since the area of a
trapezoid is half the sum of
the bases times the height, we
get that the area of this
trapezoid is 5/16.
Therefore, the area of the
triangle plus the trapezoid is
6/16 or 3/8, which is 0.375.
Recall that 1/3, we've just
seen, was the exact answer.
And notice how close this
approximation is to the exact
answer, even with just two
subdivisions over here.
In fact, sparing you the
details, if you now divide the
base here into four equal
parts, thus forming your
trapezoidal approximations
corresponding to what?
Altitudes of 1/16, 1/4, 9/16,
and 1, and adding up the areas
of all these trapezoids--
by the way, this is
a bit unfortunate.
This is a triangle.
But we can view a triangle as
being a degenerate trapezoid,
meaning the height here just
happens to be 0 at this
particular point.
But let's not worry
about that.
Let's just get the idea of
what the trapezoidal
approximation idea means.
We find the area of these four
trapezoids, and we use that as
an approximation for the
area under the curve.
By the way, just coming back
here for a moment, notice that
because this curve is always
holding water, the chord will
always lie above the arc.
And consequently, not only do we
get an approximation using
trapezoids this way that's
reasonably close, but we also
know by the geometry here that
our approximation must be too
large to be the right answer.
In other words, we're going to
get an over-approximation.
But watch how close we come.
Leaving these details for you to
verify, all I show here is
that if you add up the areas of
these four regions, we wind
up with 44/128, which
is 11/32.
And 11/32 is mighty close
to 1/3, being what?
11/33.
In other words, look at how
close, with just four
subdivisions, we get to an
approximation that's good for
the area under the curve,
without having to put the
squeeze on.
But to get the exact area,
we need the squeeze.
We have to push the thing from
above, from below, and show
that these two things that we're
squeezing it between, as
gruesome as it sounds, converge
towards each other.
The thing that we're looking
for is caught between them,
and consequently must
be the common limit.
That was the method of
exhaustion as known by the
ancient Greeks.
And if this seems tough to
you, think of it from two
points of view.
One, it is tough.
And secondly, if people of some
2,500 years ago were able
to do this, it should be at
least plausible that with a
little bit of effort, we can get
a good feeling for what's
going on here.
In fact, hopefully, the
exercises to this particular
unit will make this a little
bit easier for
you to see in action.
But at any rate--
let me just make a few
asides over here.
The deeper asides will be made
in greater detail in our
supplementary notes.
Notice that when we dealt with
differential calculus, it was
very, very important in
differential calculus to have
smooth curves.
For finding areas, all you need
are continuous curves.
In other words, for example,
we can find
the area of a square.
But certainly, a square
has sharp corners.
In other words, those corners
are continuous, but they're
not differentiable in terms
of the language of
differential calculus.
The point is that even
continuity can be weakened.
Let me give you a definition.
'f' is called piecewise
continuous on the interval
from 'a' to 'b' if and only if
'f' is continuous except at a
finite number of points where
it has jump discontinuities.
For example, in terms of this
particular diagram, notice
that my curve, 'y' equals 'f of
x', is discontinuous at a
finite number of points,
namely at 'c1'
and 'c2', two points.
Notice that what happens at
those two points is you have
just a finite jump
discontinuity.
The point is that whereas this
curve is not continuous,
notice that since a straight
line having no thickness has
no area, if we replace the
given curve by this one--
you see, putting in these
vertical lines--
notice that this does form
a closed region.
And to find the area of this
closed region, I can pretend
it was made up of these three
particular regular regions.
In other words, that even if I
just have jumps, since the
jump does not contribute towards
the area, there is no
harm done when one talks about
piecewise continuous in
finding areas rather
than continuous.
A second aside--
well, I've actually called this
one aside number one,
because this definition I
didn't call an aside--
but the idea is this.
Notice that up until now, we
were assuming that we had to
form our 'U sub n's and our 'L
sub n's by choosing either the
left endpoint of a partition
or the right endpoint.
What I'd like you to see also as
a generalization is that if
I pick any point between these
two extremes and form--
look, I'll call it
'c sub k' between
these two points here--
and form this particular sum,
where 'c sub k' replaces
either 'x sub k' or 'x sub 'k -
1'', that this sum here also
gives me the area of
the region 'R'.
In other words, that whatever
this sum is, it's caught
between 'U sub n'
and 'L sub n'.
And since 'U sub n' and 'L
sub n' have a common
limit of 'A sub R'--
in other words, since both
of these squeeze in
towards 'A sub R'--
this being caught between them
must also be 'A sub R'.
That's what I've
said over here.
And to see this thing in terms
of a picture, all we're saying
is that when you pick the lowest
point in the interval,
you get the rectangle that
contributes to 'L sub n'.
When you pick the highest point
in the interval, you get
the rectangle that contributes
to 'U sub n'.
Consequently, for any point
between these two extremes--
call that--that's what 'c sub k'
is, it's any point between
these two--
pick the height that corresponds
to that.
And whatever rectangle you form
this way, that rectangle
must have a greater area than
the rectangle that went into
forming 'L sub n', but a lesser
area than the rectangle
that went into forming
'U sub n'.
And consequently, that's
where this particular
result comes from.
Again, this is done in more
detail in the notes, but I
think some of these things you
should hear me say out loud
rather than to rely on
your reading it.
And finally, one more
important point.
Up until now, it's been clear
that since we're talking about
area, our region has to
lie above the x-axis.
We can remove the restriction
that 'f' be non-negative if we
replace area by net area.
In other words, all I want you
to see here is that if my
region happens to look something
like this, notice
that between 'c' and 'b',
'f of x' is negative.
Consequently, when I form things
of the form 'f of x'
times 'delta x', 'delta x' being
positive, 'f of x' being
negative, is going to give
me a negative result.
In other words, algebraically,
if I form my summation, this
portion in here will give
me a positive result.
This portion in here will give
me a negative result.
Consequently, working
algebraically, what I will
find is not the true area
but the positive
minus this amount here.
In other words, what I'll
find is the net area.
And again, this will all be
worked out in the notes.
In addition, there'll be other
refinements made in the notes,
such as that these partitions
don't have to be into equal
parts or things like this.
The important point from today's
lecture is this.
Observe that this entire study
of area is done independently
of differential calculus.
In our next lecture, we are
going to show a truly
remarkable, a wonderful
relationship between the
differential calculus of before
and the so-called area
or integral calculus
that we did today.
At any rate, until next
time, goodbye.
Funding for the publication of
this video was provided by the
Gabriella and Paul Rosenbaum
Foundation.
Help OCW continue to provide
free and open access to MIT
courses by making a donation
at ocw.mit.edu/donate.